an anaconda mother is giving birth to
live babies because anacondas are among
the 30% of snake species that do not lay
eggs these 40 babies about a third of
her body weight are saying hello to the
wilds of Venezuela the mother also
expels about a dozen orange spheroids
these are eggs that never developed into
babies although anacondas are the
largest snakes in the world this trim
down mother hasn't eaten in several
months you'll have to excuse her if she
dines on some of the eggs she's gotta
eat something so she'll be strong enough
to go out and hunt again some of her
babies are stillborn she'll also eat
those of course with 40 babies sometimes
you might accidentally taste a live one
Pat whoops sorry sorry once they're out
of moms body the babies are on their own
the first of the babies slithers off
the baby goes after its first meal but
when you're this young you tend to look
like a meal to other predators like
these piranhas for example at least the
Anaconda has stealth and pretty good
camouflage on its side the baby makes
its way through the water hyacinth ah
but then stealth fails and the baby
wanders into the open
it's a sad tale
well come on I mean they are piranhas
another baby races off to safety or not
like most cats ocelots don't care for
water that much but since these
anacondas aka water Boas prefer to be in
water more than any other type of boa
even staying submerged for 10 minutes at
a time
the Ocelot has to adapt giant otters and
Caymans also prey on the baby snakes the
full-grown anaconda is one of the
world's most powerful predators and
grows up to dine on these same animals
that hunted it when it was young